previously on the walking right they can
take much farther to the riverfront
there should be just a few more blocks
up ahead and they'll be boats there sue
is he'll better be uh yeah he's right uh
what's up there ah no boats no buts
Bobby yes there's gotta be there's gotta
be why the hell are we hiding someone
came down from that building at the end
of the streets look this could be the
guy from the radio the one who's been
messing with us
what better
well it's a ninja oh go and rat
my name is I don't know beer but and I
know what is that climbing
let's Clemmy doing here did she follow
me you're not from Crawford what the
hell is Crawford oh it's a girl I didn't
see that coming
Crawford what the hell are you talking
about
don't shoot Kenny Kenny dope well he's
boss Hey this is so way
who the hell are you people we're we're
just looking for a disco okay everyone
just calm down calm down what she tells
me who the [ __ ] she is the name's Molly
Molly I'm leaving
this is kidding Clint I'm not looking
for any trouble
yeah me I shall have me you guys really
aren't from Crawford are you fellas
cropping is everything beyond that
barricade what the hell happened
you sure you want to know not really
when everything started going to [ __ ]
some people got together and sealed off
that whole neighborhood folks willing to
do anything to stay alive stop the dead
getting it I try to avoid him why let's
just say they have a zero-tolerance
policy for anyone who won't or can't
live by their rules so how'd you know we
weren't there yeah because there are no
children in Crawford why no jelly no -
why not no children no elderly no one
with an advanced medical condition
basically no one who might be a burden
on the community
Crawford's all about the survival of the
fittest
that's how they survived while the rest
of the world went to [ __ ] around Jesus
Christ
damn girl what exactly did Crawford do
with all these birds what happened to
them well you met some of them already
nice [ __ ] yeah anyone who got sick
anyone too old anyone they figured
wasn't strong enough to survive then
those people were just mouths to feed a
drain on their precious resources
oh they said everyone in Savannah knew
what was going on inside Crawford got
passed around like a ghost story except
this one was true
huh I want to know what Clem is doing
here do you know who's been ringing
those bells all over town yeah that
would be me
ah Lee I knew she was the one who's been
following us [ __ ] whips get that
finger out of my face grandpa before I
straight up your ass I haven't been
following you I don't even know who the
hell you people are calm down Kenny the
voice on the radio was a guy remember
yeah well whoever you are ringing those
bells this morning nearly got us all
killed
no one cares what shots no I'm how I get
around I ring a bell in one neighborhood
to attract the local geeks for I see
some time to scavenge the areas they
cleared out Deeks so what you gon ya
know like at the carnival they'll eat
anything alive or dead right doesn't
take much time art the dead bunch of
dumbasses you just got to move fast get
in and out before they start to wander
back again look I'm gonna ask you people
again you're not from Crawford so who
the hell are you what are you doing here
we're trying to find a buddy we'll
hopefully get our people out of here
find something safe yeah good luck with
that
anyone with a boat took it out of here
as soon as people started eating each
other
I need that got left behind Crawford's
stripping for parts cars - there's gotta
be something if there was do you think
I'd still be here I've been over every
inch of this city this whole place has
picked clean that good you want to keep
your voice down [ __ ] since you're not
getting any boat I'd advise you folks to
go back to where you came from before
right
[Music]
hey guys there that's a party over here
gunshot must have brought it back I mean
what are you doing here
whoa Clint hi Molly's crazy hey you're
just gonna leave us here sorry I'd love
to miss that part of our conversation
where you became my problem
you leave us here please oh you can't
say nothing those little eyes come on
make it fast
my god oh my but don't worry Clementine
I got this why not just jump over it it
can't be that difficult
oh no it's time to take that gun but
that's their favorite one oh [ __ ]
whoa that is the closet club a faceplant
that got a hug
Clementine can you hear me if you can
hear me just get back to the house okay
I'll meet you there
host Clemmy doing there in the first
place she's probably following me
it's not safe I tell you [ __ ] and why
wouldn't you want it Clementine enade
why would they kill kids I mean
Clementine is better than Ben at least
all right we got to solve puzzles I
don't like suey
we're not a gun though but do we have
the ice big thing why would you want to
pry that open probably a better question
yeah that's how vid whoa careful Lee you
don't want to end up falling down in
that dirt you could probably get really
sick and when you get sick you becomes
am be fine that rats yeah all right
let's keep going but we got more rats
cool good bad what are you doing in I
can hear them but I can't see that oh
[ __ ] I better sneak careful or I could
drown them I don't know which way though
this way to the left to the left
everything you own in a box to the left
water I love water well oh [ __ ] what do
I do
oh I could use it on the other thing all
right let's take this way back
how are you walking what am i all right
carefully carefully you don't want to
learn the zambese now do you wha Jania
spits strikes again
all right let's drown some Sam B can you
drown zombies well I guess we're about
to find out
all right that water I love boy I like
them on Facebook come here [ __ ]
and then I go in here and then we go
around jump around
[Applause]
[Laughter]
all right you can run you can hide oh
[Music]
he's gonna be Sami fine okay you deserve
better oh [ __ ] I actually like chuckle
Oh bear
I don't like compares but then I thought
I'd like it in and then what are you
doing
ice pick vengeance mother dumb thing
what stop with the [ __ ] jump [ __ ]
oh why would you not admit No damn it
let go it's not cool I just pick a polka
that's right I've heard of that Hey
I'll either let me race comes back your
face much prettier stupid jump scares
jumping me like a sir anger drak yerpa
why are we going in there well if you
were as good as opening pry bars as you
are is talking to yourself and we might
have a chance fine maybe Chuck can help
you well what do we do oh [ __ ] are you
going it's just our side I thought that
sorry hey sorry alright whoa hello let's
see I'm day we could use the ladder and
get up I guess but how
you're not gonna make it what hello it's
not just a sign it's a cover-up hello
who put that up there let me use my two
legs maybe Shh poor shocked man I was
hoping he would come back or some [ __ ]
like that
a fallout shelter oh we're gonna enter
this oh no we're gonna enter the crowd
cross the cross
cracker look at all this it's enough to
keep people alive for months really is
it that much we enter the Crawford by
accident what I am your destiny nobody
just lost trying to get back home yeah
well you took a wrong turn this is our
home not yours and you're not welcome
here look I'm sorry disturbed you folks
I'll just be going you can't let him
leave he's from Crawford if he goes back
there and they find out we're down here
are you from Crawford they don't lie to
me I know where else can he be from
everywhere else around here is dead okay
we get the small group hoping to find a
boat we just want to get out of here
about you just let me go ain't no boats
around here Crawford took everything I
know yeah her son's a painter you can't
let him leave well I will yours cute
behind ahead why not be more of a mercy
than anyone from Crawford ever showed us
think Vernon what do you think they'll
do if they find out we're down here
right under their feet
you're right I'm not free I'm not from
croppers I'm not from Crawford but I saw
what they did up there made me sick not
like their and I don't think you are
either
I think you're a good man keep back or I
swear I'll shoot I told you he's lyin he
is one of them kill him before he kills
us you can't kill me he said keep back
or I'll shoot the nose keeping bad are
they drawing penises or I'll shoot I got
you all wrong it's okay Berner what the
hell are you doing Vernon looks like the
tables have turned now searching that my
dad you're really not from Crawford no
sorry
well no we are with a meant to be we got
out a look-alike tart it's sealing up
the place you know started weed not the
sick and the old so they're perfect
survivors Society wouldn't be threatened
no room for weakness or vulnerability in
their little master race you don't look
that old so you see were sick we're all
members of a cancer survivors group that
used to meet here at the hospital
we're in remission but that wasn't good
enough for Crawford they'd already
rounded up five of us before the rest of
us managed to hole up and hide from them
down here this whole basements been
abandoned for years there oh it's a
morgue
that's [ __ ] disturbing ironies always
high on my list when I'm looking for a
place to survive how did you find your
way down here
my group and I were up by the river
looking for a boat now I just want to
get out of here and find them again
well that sewer system you came through
runs all over the city it'll take you
wherever you want to go well that's
convenient
those sewers are like a damn maze any
chance you could help me find my way
back look I'd like to help you but we've
all got our own problems who of our
group is sick need constant care and I'm
the only doctor here besides why should
we help you because you're fat and ugly
because this is your other option sorry
friend I'm not buying it I didn't mean
to click language I've seen my share of
murderers since this all started seen
too many if he was the type to do
violence he'd have done it already I'm
calling your bluff
your move no wait listen to me
I've I have to get back climate sorry
for security I just want to get back to
my people back to Clementine
she she daughter yeah yeah she's
probably already wondered where I am
well we can't have that can we
what the hell are you doing it's alright
free I had a daughter too
lost her in the first days I'll be
damned if I'll just sit back and let
that happen to someone else hell yeah I
need you here don't worry I'll be back
before you know it
let's go see about your daughter ah but
Lee's dad what about at least dad
alright time
Klim they're not gonna be here uh again
Marley oh hey you made it back
where's clementines he didn't tell you
about me
understandable I guess I'm the one who
put that beating on him when he tried to
jump me back at the river it was a
fossil wow that's nice this is Vernon
he's a doctor he helped me get back here
after we got separated I think you have
something that belongs to me
why is Clementine
right it's kind of Club Lee thank god
you're back
Krista what's wrong it's Oh Mead he's
gotten worse much come on
we have a man wonder who's this oh and
we have a doctor he's a doctor
oh thank god could you take a look at
him
I mean he came to say where help us
please I'll see what I can do
take me to them huh
omid honey you're gonna be alright we
brought a doctor alright let's take a
look at him I work better without an
audience now why don't you go find your
little girl yeah come on
Clementine Clementine race she could she
be in the study Clementine you in here
where is she where is she
clinic low whenever I climb deep I don't
you may be in the bathroom Clementine
you're here no what about bedroom can
she just ask someone everything okay in
there just leave us alone I'd be doing
in there oh that's a doctor room that's
a bit awkward my opinion and my opinion
doesn't matter the matter Clementine
but it's the eyes are [ __ ] scaring me
hello mommy Molly are you doing oh you
know just poking around you won't find
anything we already searched the place
you'd be surprised what people missed
trust me I've been doing this for a
while where's Clementine don't ask me
I'm not her keeper hey do I look like
I'm in the mood to be jerked around
where did she yeah where is she last I
saw she was downstairs with your redneck
friend in that college kid who hangs
around with him why don't you go bug
then all right fine
I don't like this music man
Clementine where are you I really don't
like this Clementine Kyle please
no she's not Anthony oh hey you made it
back good job good job
what the hell do you think you're doing
what does it look like we're to get the
bottle found it you all throw down again
like back on the train is that fight
better when I'm shit-faced what the [ __ ]
man where it's climbing
Don't Tell miss you got kidnapped
getting wasted it's not gonna help
anyone yeah well what is we are [ __ ]
I'm glad you've given up there's not a
single boat left in Savannah no way out
we got walkers all around us that crazy
[ __ ] on the radio messing with us he'll
if now at the time for a drink
then what the [ __ ] are you doing and
what is this Ben don't you yeah you
better not do that Ben bad have you seen
Clementine damned if I know
gotta be around here somewhere Ben I
gave you one job when I left here take
care of Clementine then she shows up out
on River Street looking for me the hell
happened
hey don't put all that on me no me he
took a turn for the worse and Krista
asked me to help I'm sorry I'm doing the
best I can here [ __ ] you man you saw he
was frantic and things got where is she
I told Clementine to stay put what else
could I do
don't be sorry just tell me where the
hell she is now I think she went out to
play in the backyard on her own with no
one watching her man will you get off my
back and she's I know I will slap your
[ __ ] favors I don't like this music I
don't like where this is going
from the time Femi Clementine oh no
Peter Pine does not play games
grabbin time
she in the doghouse maybe please be in
the doghouse
whoa
it's gonna be a zombie
oh thank god how are you doing hey girl
a boat
everything's gonna be all right
everything's nuts we're nuts we're all
right
well who's the dummy with a mustache now
huh
I breath I can edit here I compared you
know I subscribe to keep my bread today
and I'll see you next episode
you